I want to call this next clip ironic, but
it's so disgusting that maybe I'll call it
tragically ironic. Fox News had to literally
interrupt its own fearmongering about Hispanic
immigrants at the u s border in El Paso, Texas
to cut to breaking news that an anti-immigrant
extremist went to the border in El Paso and
shot people because he believes Hispanic immigrants
are taking over the country. The exact thing
that Fox news was fearmongering about when
they broke into their own coverage, and before
we get into this, just to be like crystal
clear, I know I've mentioned this, this story
will be demonetized by Youtube. We will earn
no money on this bun, but we consider this
obviously so important that we have to cover
it, so please consider supporting us directly@joinpacman.com
share the video like the video comment on
the video. That's all really important. Even
if we don't make any money from the story.
Let's look at a video. Fox News spent their
entire morning on Saturday scaring people
with the number of illegals expected to cross
all of this other stuff. Then a story about
drug smuggling. At the border and then right
in the middle of a report. Here we go. Literally
going to their reporter who happens to already
be in El Paso to fearmonger about the border
and then they go to a report of the shooting
that has taken place. Take a look.
Oh, this crisis on the border likely not going
to be over anytime soon. At least from a congressional
standpoint, several Democratic lawmakers told
me that there is almost no chance of congress
tackling the loopholes in our immigration
system before the next election. Meaning this
crisis more than a hundred thousand people
crossing the border each of the last four
months now is going to continue for at least
another year and a half if not more. Jillian
Garrett,
thanks for that. We're going to know now too,
a Fox News alert. We're getting more active
shooter situation in El Paso, Texas residents
there are being warned to stay clear of the
Cielo vs Vista Mall area with police officials.
The scene is
still active. Can it be any more direct than
this? Fox News had to briefly interrupt their
fearmongering over Hispanic immigrants and
quote illegals to report that someone radicalized
by fear-mongering about Hispanic immigrants
and quote illegals went to the border and
killed 20 people, a border town. I understand
he wasn't literally at the border in El Paso,
which is where a lot of this is happening
and then as I've already told you, went directly
back into the fearmongering did Fox News about
how video games may actually be the cause
we need to be looking at for this shooting.
I actually did something this weekend. I never
do. My curiosity got the best of me. I turned
on Fox News to see their coverage of the shooting.
I watched about 20 minutes. This was the 20
minutes I watched were hours after the shooters
right-wing manifesto had been found and published.
We knew the right way and radicalization and
motivation of the shooter and in those 20
minutes, those 20 minutes were all about the
shooting that I watched on Fox News.
They didn't mention the ideology or the motivations
of the shooter. Once they said he had a manifesto,
they claimed that they weren't going to say
what was in it in the same way that they're
not going to say the shooter's name. And of
course these two things are very different.
You might've noticed, you maybe didn't, I
haven't mentioned any of the shooters names
from this weekend and this entire show, but
I've told you plenty about their political
background and their radicalization and their
backgrounds. It is not the same thing as not
mentioning the name. And also I actually don't
know, does Fox News not say the name of Islamic
shooters? I genuinely don't know the answer
to that. So we've got to stop funding Fox
News. Okay, we've got to cut the cord and
support programs you like. A lot of people
don't realize this, but when you have a cable
TV subscription, a piece of that goes to Fox
News according to a report in variety, Fox
News makes a dollar 55 per cable subscriber.
Okay? Imagine how many of you could cut your
cable, figure out what you want to watch and
get that directly. There are ways to get your
news channels or if you want content that's
on Netflix or Amazon prime or whatever the
case may be, and put that dollar 55 that you're
currently putting towards Fox News towards
a show you like. It could be the David Pakman
show. It could be a different one. Do the
numbers. We have 710,000 youtube subscribers.
We have a growing following on twitch. We
have 200 radio and TV stations. Imagine if
just 10% of our audience cut their cable,
sent us a dollar 55 a month and then put the
rest towards other shows that they find valuable
that they like. Imagine how strong independent,
progressive media would be if we were to do
that. Uh, we will take a quick break. Make
sure you are following me on
instagram@daviddotpacmanandfollowtheshowontwitchattwitch.tv
slash David Pacman. If you have Amazon prime,
you can subscribe to us on twitch with twitch
prime. It costs you nothing. It counts as
a paid
subscription for us. A fantastic way to support
the work
that we're doing.